austin texas the middle class famous
store is coming to town we're going to
be at the moon tower comedy festival
this week april 22nd we're doing our
stand-up show and playing ayg with the
crowd and we're doing a live podcast you
can either get badges or you can get
tickies come see us let's party we're
also gonna be in denver phoenix salt
lake city pittsburgh buffalo detroit
chicago chicago rosemont second show at
it in chicago only late show tickets
left in chicago get those tickets now
it's a party we'll see you there welcome
to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage sure is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that they grow to be classy
yeah they're just a big old piece of
trash
i'm your host stage foley kind of the
resident bad boy around this uh this
operation coming at you from down here
at antoni's basement uh she
unfortunately did not make it
to work today okay second no call no
show uh-huh so she's gonna be back up
there laying on the couch looking for
unemployment i don't know what's going
on with this broad she can't hold down a
job where's she working nowadays she's
over there denny's okay she's hostessing
you know
she could work up to manager if she
plays her cards right yeah nightmare
night time manager well that's where you
got to start shifting she ain't starting
with she ain't starting on a brunch
shift yeah you don't start out as a ceo
we can't all be you sure speaking of my
co-hosts ladies and gentlemen the ceo
founder of ru garbage he's killing it in
the polls these days yeah the likability
over there on the patreon you took a
heavy hit
in the polls man i am i am the favorite
by a landslide this week
because you were a bozo talking about
living living long enough to become the
bad guy now i'll tell you that i went
from batman to the joker
one episode it's yikes you know how bad
you got to be for me to be the good guy
i'm a prick ladies and gentlemen you're
looking great over there man the kid's
doing all right like how the [ __ ] does
he still friends with this idiot
he summers in europe he winters in
wildwood new jersey going down tonight
give it up for kj hey gang kevin james
ryan thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on
itunes fall video available on youtube
those numbers are turn the roof
legitimately legitimately cooking what
about that other thing what's it called
uh is that cameo.com no who was it jg
wentworth i want my money
patreon.com let me tell you something
musk i know you got your little greasy
fingers on twitter you stay away from
[ __ ] jack and sam's operation that's
that's that that that's their show let
them kings live yeah that's right
they're doing they're doing the lord's
work out there you do your rockets
whatever you want to do you leave
patreon.com alone yes uh i should take
it public
which stole a couple of shares my way
you know what i mean advisory shares i
watch shark tank
uh
patreon.com you sign up you get bonus
episodes at ayg yup you get episodes of
hard feelings which is a completely
different podcast all together
and if you're wondering what happened in
l.a we did an emergency episode this
week go check dead out yeah the airbnb
saga you get live streams at the top two
tiers uh where we every month where we
play ayg with uh in the live stream it's
a good [ __ ] time those are hangs dude
those are good hangs everybody's
in having fun a couple of bernies a
couple of bernies a couple of jazz
cigarettes too on there i see some
people doing it
a couple of miles davises if you know um
but also if you join now i don't want to
make this sound too [ __ ] sales but
not everybody understands if you're not
aware you sign up now you get a whole
year full of [ __ ] all the back
episodes it's all there for five or i
would recommend the ten dollar level
always but go for value that's just me
and these trying economic times get the
most information going out the [ __ ]
window see those interest rates don't
know what that means nope
gang having a nice quick shout out to
one of my best pals in the whole wide
world we love him another kid [ __ ]
star on the rise around his company idea
man
couple of good ideas this week knocking
it out of the park this kid this kid
doesn't [ __ ] with albums he only makes
singles he's got a lot of dj khaled and
i'm telling you right now and word on
the street the boss is really grooming
and become on-air talent i am yeah okay
copy cam coming soon toby cam coming
soon stop saying that because we
promised it like two months ago we
haven't done it yet
people are all up my ass oh i hemmed us
up getting kicked out of california yeah
give it up for t-bone mcscuffins mr toby
mcmullen everybody what's up dudes what
a magic man dude on the walk here right
i walked past
jp morgan okay right never met him the
guy
yeah dude he's out there with a top hat
and a monocle what do you mean oh
sweatpants crazy dude you're like 500
years old dude no but uh joe sanegado
had the j.p morgan card correct no yes
morgan stanley no merrill lynch merrill
lynch very old school then that's when i
walk by i walk by merrill lynch i think
this guy stinks
all i know is he was a homeless guy
asking for a sandwich he just talked you
up for five minutes yeah what i mean
come on now
[Laughter]
but i walk past and the their tagline is
wealth management yes
that's good yeah that's all right i
didn't know yeah you didn't know what
wealth was i sure don't yeah i got a
venmo credit card that's how we're doing
over here
dirtbag inc i'm trying to get her it
should be the name of that should be the
name of my personal llc dirt bag
i felt like a real bummer bubble gummer
i walked past a sign i went well wealth
management i only i would never feel
comfortable in there i'm i come what do
you think you have to have in the
account just to hold it
wealth because yeah whatever that is
more than my four grand i'll tell you
that right now leave one of your kids in
there for the weekend
do you have a do you have a uh
a minimum amount you have to keep in
your checking account or savings account
probably prob yeah i would assume t-bone
oh no yeah you don't know that but
probably what are you talking about i
don't read anything i just click the
boxes sign
i don't know anything i don't know what
i have i don't know if i have checking
no checking i know my car got declined
when i was trying to buy cigarettes for
me and josh potter out there
i blamed it on my wife
she's not home ordering amazon i think
goddamn seamless she's killing me he's
like yeah i know i'm zero i would never
take an account that's when you get into
wealth oh you have to keep seven grand
in here okay no problem go right ahead
i'll move that right now
from my mom's account i'll just take my
lollipop and leave please thank you very
much
um what
i thought of something this morning i
wanted to ask you real quick before we
get into the cues because gang as you
know it's a family episode we'll be
reading uh your questions okay from the
place my poofing what's going on you got
low flow showerhead vibes going on right
now
you get a little pomade in there or
something dude
oh you're looking that's not i mean you
got a good head of hair that's a you got
a that's a rough do like a moment
[Laughter]
looks like you're trying to get in
studio 54.
what i know jerry let me in i was
talking about a lady trying to get in
the studio
i got high hair putting a hole in the
ozone with that [ __ ] hairspray there
daddy though yeah i was down on my mom's
and she doesn't have the kind of
equipment that that that my lady gets
it's just suave
original not even strawberry or nothing
it's brutal she does the dishes with it
it's a nightmare
i'm gonna jack my [ __ ] all up and the
soap that they have down there patty get
some something with a little moisturizer
in it jesus christ
talking about old-school irish
you know i feel like i'm an angela's
ashes [ __ ] like grill cream
is there anything that is in the
bathroom that has a pump top oh [ __ ]
yeah dude
the ketchup yeah
we're gonna eat a plain hot dog in the
shower what are we [ __ ] [ __ ] what
are we doing here she stole a setup from
citizens bank park you got the relish
machine and everything
i assume you're not a relish guy on your
hot dogger you would assume correct yeah
t-bone i'm gonna play jane yeah i don't
like knocking on nothing
unless it's a craft cindy
um what i was down here today had to
fill up the old uh the old vehicle um
and something struck me you have a new
car
i do it's a kia do you ever
go for anything other than regular are
you a plus man or a premium if you're
feeling it do you ever mix it up no
never right and my stepdad he used to
have a big suburban and i remember on
christmas
he would fill up with premium as like a
treat to the truck
because she's been good this year i
gotta take care of her only time you'd
ever do premium oh man
my my parents looked at that [ __ ] like
that's all dirt dude i mean we are
that's trash my p my mom always said
that was a scam she looked at that [ __ ]
like it was bear spray there was no way
we were getting anywhere near that [ __ ]
no that's crazy to me that's how they
get you yeah
i just saw i heard it's
supposed to go with the plus i think
you're only but i think it's like you
got to do that all the time or something
i don't think like one and a half that's
not happening it's not like an oil
change
merrill lynch get the [ __ ] out of here
um that gas is getting pricey i just saw
a video on something i don't know it
came across my desk while i was doing
some research for the program over there
um
this girl which kind of makes sense
because what is it it's like 80 90 and
93 or the number or like 87 what are the
numbers the octane numbers it's like
sorry you're talking about metallica
tour dates
load reload i'm talking about riding the
lightning
uh no it's like 87 89.91 or something
like that
she thought she goes get the old stuff
don't pay for the new stuff she thought
it was the year it was extracted she
thought it was like wine or something
she goes get the 87 don't pay for the
new stuff
the guy's like what
i'll do a 72 diesel be nice try it out
that was always a that was always
instilled in us too what if you ever put
diesel in the car i'll kill you my buddy
did it my buddy did my buddy uh pat not
uh
do you get before
no it stalls at the stalls at the tank
at the at the uh at the at the tank
that's got a ruined car
oh yeah
i mean i think yeah i mean the car yeah
i don't think it was like one of those
reliant k's or so it was a real car
i mean this is like 2005 or like it was
like senior high school you're driving
like you're driving like an 88
it's bad when your car's older than you
yeah that's a tough look um
but and it's all it's seized up like you
turn it on and it pumps it through and
yeah it's over um i'm sticking with
regular
yeah no matter how big we get
i don't know maybe
premium would be nice uh some cars only
run on it that's when you know you're
that's all right not only run on it but
it's for the end like the beamers and
[ __ ] you got to go high-end really yeah
i believe i don't know i've never owned
one but that's what i heard keo put
anything in there and put bananas in
there
runs on prune juice
if you're in a pinch
um i had this today which we've spoken
about but i had another level uh twist
to it i'm going down the shore today yes
you are uh which did you know it was
called wild woods and not wildwood
it's the wild woods yeah it is north
wylwood wildwood and wildwood crest the
wild woods that's real trashy and then
there's so there's wild wood proper wild
ones north wild wildwood
and then wall
yikes
nance used to see the wildlife the wild
woods uh yeah there's three of them that
that compose the wild woods
dirtbag voltron uh the irish riviera as
it's been referred to
um but well the claims ain't fresh no
and the bills ain't paid
uh i'm going down obviously you know
zero clean clothes
absolutely
zero i put my last pair of clean undies
that i had on
today to come here you're welcome nice
um i got a pair if you need them
yikes cover the car um
so i'm like that's one thing i'm [ __ ]
you know will you do will you do the
laundry when you get down here you're
gonna do the laundry when i get down
there at my mom's but here's the real
dirtbag twist
i'm not staying at my mom's i got an
airbnb down the block but i'm gonna go
to my mom's and do the laundry
and take it back to my airbnb drop off
pickup what are you doing i don't think
she's gonna do it wouldn't she though
your mom washed your clothes i don't
know probably [ __ ] recently no never
oh really i mean when i moved at least
new york maybe if like i go home and i
leave a pair of [ __ ] undies socks and
you know a church she'll throw it in
she'll do that with like the
miscellaneous oh patty's great with that
yeah that would say a lot front door
surface why you are wearing little
plastic things and everything extra
starch whatever you want and i don't
know what she has this concoction that
she uses to get the stains out it's like
two parts vinegar one part oxi clean a
little bit of gatorade two parts you
need to grow the [ __ ] up and start doing
your own goddamn spray she lets it sit
out in the sun in the backyard when are
you gonna let that stop at some point
she's gonna be an old woman that you're
just taking advantage of now some would
say that's already that's what i'm
saying
she does it good what do you want i mean
you're almost 50 yeah and she's doing
your laundry yes she is that's crazy
dude and you have no shame on that no i
love it smells fresh she's good too you
don't feel bad that this poor woman's
got to go through your dirty drawers she
likes to do it
no one likes cleaning your underwear i'm
telling you she loves it no that's
insane system down and everything
what's the thing where you're
embarrassed for someone else fram
shannon frem shootin shaymin friend
shaman yeah i got that
all the time around
you're jealous is what you want no you
just live in a bizarro world where you
dude you're 46.
you're a business owner she don't let me
touch the machine she don't want me near
it
what yeah she doesn't like anybody
touching her she ruined patty you're
ruining this yeah you got to ban
merchandise over here no you didn't got
to cut the cord on this fat ass you're
the best do the sheets too will you had
a little mess in there last night oh
yeah she's worried you're gonna plug it
in wrong
[Laughter]
yeah for the new listeners everything in
foley's house is completely unplugged
including the washer when it's not in
use except for one power strip that has
the entire township hooked up to it
[ __ ] wild
literally it's like going back in time
in that house
man it's a good time
anywho
it's a goddamn family episode yeah it is
where we answer your questions
you choose
uh it was actually pretty funny i was
talking to mr mercy last night on the
phone and he hit me with the real life
you choose
i go dude you just hit me with a
youtubes you could ah [ __ ] he's all he
was all jammed he was all fired up shout
out to that pole version shout out to mr
verzie who's gonna be making a return
here quite soon
i'd like to hear that a little class in
his joint i know finally got again what
do you think he would say if he knew
because you're about the same age as him
you're probably older than him
what do you think mr verzi would say if
he knew your mom was doing your laundry
i have a slight feeling
that you're nuts if you think mr verzi
lets his mother do his laundry i bet you
she did it i i was three years younger
than four
i know his mom i know his mom was really
on point growing up yeah growing up i
bet you she did it for i did it she she
probably did it past when he when when
he you know when he was a kid
yeah but you're way past you being a kid
true you shouldn't even be doing it for
your kid if you had kids you shouldn't
even be doing it for your kids my mom
will do it
they're cranky dude you're closer to
discount coffee than you are to being a
kid yeah closer to discount coffee
senior citizen old man what do they get
free coffee
they get a discount
yeah dude no they don't senior citizens
gonna get a deal on coffee you get a
deal on everything
old bags ain't got much of a much time
left you know what you're going down at
canal street get your license
tell you that
get my laundry done and 20 cents off a
cup of decaf
[Music]
you're getting a fake id to say you're
65.
so you can get buy one get one sausage
biscuit
is that what it is
i know tgi fridays runs a pretty nice
special for veterans on uh memorial day
the crux of our relationship i think
where most of our most of our budding
heads comes from
and this i'm not kind of
comment on it and move on is the fact
you don't think there's anything wrong
with your mother doing your laundry at
46 years old that's what i think
that that was an aha moment for me ever
going i just have to move on from these
things because i drive myself that's
going to bother me for four days i'll
tell you what i'll write that down i'll
put it no i'm saying there's nothing you
need to do it's something i need to do
and just go like oh i live in a role
where that's insane i do it when i'm
here when i'm home but if i have dirty
stuff there hold on i'm just saying you
still live in a row where you're like oh
yeah that's completely normal that's
where i'm going oh
sometimes i forget we don't live in the
same reality she's on point man she
likes to do it she loves me i don't know
what to tell you and she does it really
good the clothes but that's why you're
having her do it
you're getting off with the ashy she
likes doing it or whatever whatever
no one would like
handling your raw undies there's no one
in the world
who would like you going i'll hear these
two that's a [ __ ] take him right off
in front of her
dude time to air out in the hamper
because sometimes they refresh there's
like a half life on it it's crazy isn't
it if you've got a pair of undies
sitting in the hamper for a week and you
got to go back you go to the bottom and
you give them a whiff they're all right
yeah back in the package i know same
thing with uh basketball shorts too i
wear basketball shorts for like a few
days not for basketball no and they have
a uh they have a scent to them in in the
nether region that is a tough look it's
probably real homelessy
we got a power line they're in between
places i apologize but if you let that
sit for a little bit whoo
it's like neo coming back to life like
eats itself or something i don't know
what's happening kid let's talk about
all forms all foreign baby best in the
biz best in the biz all form now of
course if you listen to this broadcast
for a little while you know about helix
mattresses yeah well guess what what
helix got out of the bedroom and into
the living room because they're making
sofas now with a fantastic company
called all form yes for starters all
form is the easiest way you can
customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you pick your fabric
if you want spill stain scratch
resistance you pick the color the color
the legs the size the shape whatever you
want to fit perfect for your home they
got arm chairs love seats up to eight
seat sectionals if you got that many
friends or just like to sprawl out a bit
uh all firm sofas are delivered directly
to your home with fast free shipping
right now if you buy a sofa from
traditional retailer could take months
to arrive yeah supply chain not all form
nope uh takes a few weeks to arrive in
the mail and all you assemble it
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i put the one over there together
by myself probably carried it in with a
couple of guys though because it was so
heavy now comes all bing bang boom
slide it in pop it open pop it together
it's a wrap t-bone's sitting on it right
now he's got his feet on it get your
feet off i see gum on the bottom of your
shoe a little dirt ball uh and if you're
getting the sofa without trying it
sounds a little risky you don't need to
wear you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that's more than three
months and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up and you'll get a full refund
but i'm telling you you're gonna like
these things there you go find the
perfect sofa check out all form.com
garbage all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners at allforum.com
garbage one more time all form dot com
slash garbage 20 off go do it now cap
let's talk about athletic greens
athletic greens ag-1 ag-1 number one in
the gym i can tell you that right now i
can tell you why i started taking
athletic greens because they sent it to
us for free and i wanted to give it a
shot and then what gave it a shot
started taking it to my workouts with me
yeah powers me through my workouts motor
gut health immunity all-natural tastes
great i can't say enough about it you
gotta try it it's like a super duper
multivitamin this says 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole food source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens
whatever the heck they may or may not be
that sounds like superhuman stuff i know
i'll lift this table
guys it's lifestyle friendly whether you
eat keto paleo vegan dairy-free or
gluten-free contains contains less than
one gram of sugar no gmos no nasty
chemicals no artificial flavoring and it
still tastes good delicious everybody's
taking some sort of multivitamin you got
this you got two of those you take this
every six hours at this that knocks a.g
not a g1 knocks that all out one stop
shop one stop shop take the powder dump
it in a cup of water slam it down please
send me this cool little thermos i know
it's a wrap uh reclaim your health and
arm your immune system with convenient
daily nutrition uh alls is just one
scoop one scoop and a cup of water every
day that's it no need for a million
pills like i've stated prior to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com garbage again that's
athletic greens.com garbage take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
do it let's get into a couple uh patreon
questions excellent also we just got
back from the road out there in uh
la la land san francisco and la jolla
uh
we got a i got i got two heaters that we
couldn't get to in the live shows that i
want to get into here i love it uh also
we'll be in austin
the week this is coming out friday night
for uh live ayg stand up we play oig
with the crowd and then uh we're doing
our show we're doing our show which is
awesome which is great at the
stateside theater or something alone
friday night april 22nd come the [ __ ]
out and see us get tick it's gonna be a
late show we're gonna be booze there's
gonna be a hoot anytime get them tickies
uh then also we're gonna be doing a live
pod later on in the weekend guests to be
announced yeah later date gonna be fun
um
the guess is barack obama
i could fly patty down interview her we
should get patty in here ooh no we
should get patty on shark tank to sell
her stain removal
whatever she's got that's not a bad idea
[ __ ] i gave the recipe away i didn't say
what kind of gatorade though
so there you go
that ain't white glacier whatever the
[ __ ] these bozos you're drinking
glacier cherries is your son a fat piece
of [ __ ] and you had to
you had to become a scientist to clean
his dirty underwear then i got the deal
for you
do you still do your middle-aged son's
laundry
oh god you are
something else big man thank you
so was that cold sore moving on
i got a little stinger little little
little love bite going on yeah i've had
to split the patreon with that thing in
a couple of days too
he wants to cut that guy wet
yikes
hurts too they hurt
hurt we're lucky we don't shoot this
thing in 3d
it's coming
the seats are moving around
[Music]
i think it was the sun in california is
what made it come out yeah or the herpes
in your body
[Laughter]
one of the other guys could be the sun
could be that i'm infected
i don't know what kind of detergent my
mom's using but i think i'm allergic to
it
yeah i got a little stinger thanks for
calling that out piece of [ __ ] yeah like
you wouldn't call it out if i had it oh
man you're lucky i might make out with
it just so you get it
a couple of stingers lift your underwear
all right let's get into it that can be
a ring
just figure out
um
let's see here all right this was from
the la jolla show this from michael c
this was a banger that we didn't get to
it was just funny what's the last thing
you used a paperclip for we all know it
wasn't clipping papers together
[Laughter]
it's clipping papers together use a
stapler there is a uh bag of
uh yeah a bag of stroman
wheat bread at my parents right now with
a paper clip on it oh my god yeah
that's tough that's a tough one
yeah i don't know the last i don't even
have paper clips
but it was for sure to like reset the
modem or something you know what i mean
you got to like undo it and push that
button i love it having a having one of
those around is great i love taking a
paper clip apart
doing that and you know what i love now
too which i hate it when i was a kid are
the the black clips the binder clips
are fantastic yeah we use those all the
time like the big ones they use for
chips and pretzels and a lot of stuff
there's tons of them in in the drawer
because remember eating at an office max
because remember for a while they have
ones for ship clips yeah yeah yeah
they never really we just stole them
they sucked they would break they didn't
play with them yeah
those you know what else could kind of
kick rocks the corn and the cob holders
never a fan no
uh they were always fun to play with a
kid if i can stab someone what up i
think my brother stabbed me with one
when i was a kid you know what was
what's your take on this
right you get you go over to someone's
house and you go oh doritos it's like an
open bag like you know it's
folded up with say with a binder clip on
it i've seen this before
but
the bags cut did you ever see that they
cut the top of the bag off
that's just weird that's psycho stuff
and any of the cutting of anything like
that just fold it fold it tuck it in you
get a tighter seal that's up there with
the half a [ __ ] tube of toothpaste
that's
a tube of toothpaste yeah you cut it in
half and leave that there
i've seen that yeah it's no good mm-hmm
no no not a fan none of that [ __ ]
because you want the extra so you can
fold it that's what i'm saying get
tighter to get a tighter seal on there
obviously food scissors or regular
scissors whatever ice pops hair whatever
you need will do
i'm okay uh scissors
are a utility player in the ryan plenty
of summers i wish i had scissors for my
ice pops for my freeze pops yeah that's
what i'm talking about you used to have
to chew and bite them or use a steak
knife i always like to think actually
you could take a lot off the top and get
like a little nice appetizer
how many of those you eat at once back
in the day sure okay
man um
[Laughter]
there's a new fat cord coming everybody
strap in the garage fridge of my mom may
or may not have been recently turned on
and stocked
it's like a trout pond in there
fantastic nice dude getting ready for
summer a day i'd probably do about an
eight piece a day i'm talking at once oh
well you get two and then maybe go back
you never just get one you go two yeah
always two always two yeah always like
water
they were all right they were all right
um shout out to freeze pops
man okay right uh sure
um what was the question
the paper clips yeah the next one is
this was from the la show i believe it's
from anthony r uh have you ever used an
old t-shirt as a car seat cover
that's
scares the [ __ ] out of me
why because people look like someone's
sitting there looks like someone's
sitting yeah and i always thought people
did that to keep people away from their
car
that really bugs me out when i'm walking
when i'm walking by a car and they have
them on both seats and you look over
you're like oh [ __ ] that guy looking at
me that's strange scary i saw the window
visor the other day my wife noticed it
and she goes that's trash in the front
front window visor ed hardy
ed hardy
in like a decent looking car that's a
giveaway i was like what was that
turn it inside out even if it was free
or i don't know i don't know anybody
still using those also it's april
what do we do it's april and it was like
57 degrees yeah what are you powder
what's going on [ __ ] vampire driving
that thing what do you think about the
things that go on the sides that they
have now not the ones that you can raise
up in the back seat those are classy but
i know my my one cousin has it on his
front like stuck on yeah now
got a big window sure and then baby in
the back sure but like if you're
if you're doing that's like that's like
a modification you would buy at the
checkout at a car wash you know what i
mean like that's
that's like all real cheap [ __ ]
anything with a suction shouldn't go on
your car anything with a suction in the
bathroom stinks too
i knocked over like [ __ ] four things
in my parents shower they had suction
cups everywhere like they're [ __ ]
like [ __ ] girls touching all four
walls too so
um yeah that suctions that [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] work
um
but all right let's get to some patreon
questions guys as you know when you sign
up for that there god damn patreon which
is true the roof part away yikes um
we will answer your garbage question on
air this one's from mickey in the same
world as the cars ever worked on a car
that's parked on the street
i've never had i've had to change tires
when you're like parallel parked
i remember guys are coming up are you
moving i'm like my [ __ ] head i'm like
dude the car's jacked up my head's i'm
not moving anytime soon you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
got three tires on this goddamn thing i
think we've mentioned this before
actually there was a big city thing
that's a city thing where you got to
kind of do it yeah but there's in my
neighborhood in washington heights
there's legit businesses businesses yeah
just on the side of the street just
working on cars that's where they show
up
they got [ __ ] car washes too you pull
up to one of those guys they got real
they got like a big conversion van with
a tank of water in the back that they
fill up every day somewhere jesus
they're in there
it's probably like 20 bucks
all hand washed they do a real nice like
unreal bridge or something
i think you got to know a guy to get
involved to get inv it's invite only
getting a haircut next to your car
getting washed under a bridge it's a
that's trash but they're very it's very
uh you know
resourceful up there if you're like hey
i gotta make some [ __ ] money gotta i
own a business on a street let's go
everybody uses it yeah and the burb's
not so not so much if you're working on
a car in your driveway
that's a tough look yeah but i guess
unless you're one of those guys that can
do that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah we
weren't we'd be out there screaming at
each other because as you know patty
used to go to the junkyard and get parts
and do [ __ ] herself put in a tail light
put in a headlight find another uh
roller for the window we do all that
[ __ ] ourselves in the dark in the
driveway on a school night and there was
some screaming you just wait till the
daytime because you gotta get to work
the next time
it's freezing cold outside i can't drive
with the windows down
it's trash
i remember the one time uh
uh
neighbors across the street were fixing
something on their car i was at my
buddy's house who lived like the next
street over and we were in his driveway
and he had a real bad group of kids that
lived across the they were just older
bad kids
just you know
real delinquents these kids yikes yeah i
never crossed into delinquency i never
got arrested as a kid that was this kid
these kids mo there was like the parents
were never home
a lot of wife beaters a lot of underage
like open underage sig smoking probably
not the best school lunches either
coming in
yeah
felt bad for those kids um just like a
rough rougher
family rest of the block was beautiful
these kids were
tough tough kids yeah
and uh they were fixing something
and
we were just we would just sit down
there and watch them
and
the [ __ ] car
from the bushes like
like a [ __ ]
hide behind the green box
um and uh
something we're checking the something
and the cap to like the [ __ ]
antifreeze or like the radiator
popped off
and [ __ ]
doused the kid with [ __ ] hot
blue goo or whatever
it was like an acid burn dude
you should have seen these dirt bags
carrying around in the front yard
throwing splashing water on get in the
pool they hopped in the neighbors some
dr pepper on him
it was a [ __ ] did he get scarred i
don't know probably cause there were a
couple of kids in my school i just
remember going i was like seven going
never working on a [ __ ] car
even if i gotta change the gas if i
gotta fill the gas tank i'm thinking
about that we were always told never
touch the radiator even with the cars i
don't touch anything yeah get the [ __ ]
out of here but i don't even like jump
in a car but i'm an older gentleman um
and back in the 80s uh i went to uh a
catholic school st nicholas st mary's
and every winner i felt like there was
one or two kids that would show up with
radiator burns the radiator went in
their house or they were playing next to
it and they got splashed with the
radiator uh steam yikes yeah
yikes is right i don't do that some kid
was [ __ ]
whoo
face full of radiator
i don't that'll ruin the holidays
um
this one's mikey ever knows someone that
could jailbreak an iphone
oh
t-bone you gotta know some dirt bags who
are jailbreaking iphones my brother was
on that [ __ ] which what does that do
because it's like it breaks the security
system so you can like input your stuff
right what does that mean yeah you can
add there's like a firewall you can add
i'm just making stuff up you're just
saying computer terms
aol
fire stick
kippy still uses yahoo to search for
stuff
i'm an aj kind of guy ask jeeves yeah he
was all right classy guy sure uh it
allows you to add third-party apps like
that aren't approved in the itunes store
so if you wanted like a bittorrent
client to download some shady [ __ ] some
stuff like that dark web kind of stuff
sure
you want to buy a mountain lion or
something like that
right i think you could do that above
board but i also think if things were
locked
like i used to have a friend who was in
the bartending business
and uh still is
but people would leave phones all the
time so he would come if you ever need
if somebody was ever jammed up and
needed a phone burner he could get his
hands on phone because people would
leave them and then now come back and
get them or whatever they get he put him
in his pocket
i didn't see anything
when they sat no so he'd be like you
would hit him up be like hey i need a
phone anybody to phone you hit him i'd
be like what do you got he'd be like oh
you know i got a
iphone 6 11 5s whatever
and they were he's like you just got to
get someone to jailbreak it though i
guess you can like activate it in your
name or something i never did it because
i rent my phone from sprint mobile to
lease
bumper to bumper warranty on that thing
yeah
um
i remember when the fire stick thing was
was happening
that's still happening you could i don't
understand you can do something and you
watch get all the channels
is that what happens yeah just like that
really you get like a usb it's called a
fire stick you got a usb or whatever i
thought amazon sold fire sticks but it
was their product and then you then you
could jailbreak yes
yeah yeah you buy a modified fire stick
so it has everything
uh unlocked for you yeah and like my
buddy i think you gotta buy that's like
every like six months or a year you
gotta like buy a new one you gotta like
re-up i can watch my show they bug them
or whatever yeah or like things get
upgraded and everything they'll pop you
for sure i can watch my shows
yeah or you can spend the you know 30
bucks a month on on hulu netflix and
[ __ ] what you do premium columba i
watch colombo youtube premium 65 bucks a
month getting bamboos on that that's
youtube tv oh yeah i got youtube tv kids
are right over there on youtube though
that's our company man sure thing should
dare say anything who runs that outfit
who owns you youtube google google
now they're good mm-hmm they're big yeah
got that right elon's making moves did
you guys know anyone who had the black
box with the illegal cable dude yeah my
brother had one not
you know maybe like
12 years ago him and his buddies lived
in a house and they had one i almost
broke my elbow on that thing
what
oh pulling your little spanx pulling the
weeds those things made me nervous as a
kid i didn't feel anxiety i didn't feel
fear like that again until i saw a pound
of weed for the first time wait you
thought the feds were going to come and
arrest you yeah dog that's crazy
my brother just asked the cable guy i
was like hey man how much you feel like
[ __ ]
do whatever he's like i got 200 bucks
and they're like there's a house full of
like four of them and they were like oh
yeah for sure everybody throw a 50 bucks
spice
everything nice that spice channel was
not too bad i mean this was
you know
a spice channel as a kid when you can't
get your hands i mean now it's all over
the place close my eyes you don't need
it now yeah yeah you know my step
brother although on cinemax and stuff
sometimes i enjoyed the
more so i don't even know they weren't
having sex for like a long time
i didn't know how it worked and my
body's like what clearly that doesn't
line up i'm like buddy i have i've never
been to the game so i don't know what
goes where but that looks pretty cool i
don't know whether i'm striking out or
stealing home
fully how disappointed were you when you
found out the spice channel wasn't about
meats
[Laughter]
dry rubs either way though huh where's
the grill what's going on
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
let's see here this one's from nicholas
this is a big hippie move do you pee
with the stall door open
you do huh yeah let him take a look i
don't like touching anything in there
really public bathrooms
[ __ ]
take a
like the turnpike bathroom or something
i don't like the stalls there's a lot of
splash backs i'm surprised
are always
[ __ ] you're standing in pee
i'm surprised you do that as uh
um nervous of a guy as you are that's
when somebody can jack you
your back's exposed
oh nobody gets killed in a [ __ ] truck
stop bathroom i mean yeah truck stop
bathroom in the middle of the night sure
that's one thing i'm talking about you
know farley's plaza on the turnpike can
get rough over there um they run out of
burgers i don't like touching anything
so i don't like clothes and locking that
door i just think about how much poops
on that [ __ ] door lock no kid let's
talk about ladder ladder wanna talk to
you about ladder gang let me tell you
something in these uncertain times you
want to make sure that you have your
family your loved one taken care of i
take care of this kind of stuff i'm
leaving it all to you by the way what do
you mean i'm leaving it all to you can't
wait both chains the watch you bought me
a couple of pairs of sneakers i'm
leaving it all to you gang you want to
make sure that you're covered you want
to make sure that you have quality life
insurance especially term coverage and
let me tell you something ladder can
help and they're fantastic yes best
thing about it one hundred percent
digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork great to apply for three
million in coverage or less we're
talking three million
cash
just yeah you just buy a little twitter
with that you need a few minutes a phone
a laptop to apply ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you find
out if you're instantly approved if you
want to talk to a person they got that
too and listen they don't work on
commission they're not going to upsell
you there you go just take care of
whatever you want get you all set up
easy peasy
and finally since life insurance costs
more as you age now is the time to cross
it off your list make a move baby go to
ladderlife.com today to see if you're
instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage
get upside baby i got a thing for you
get upside get upside let me tell you
something gang everybody loves getting a
little cash back and get upside can help
when you're getting your groceries
getting your gas going out to dinner
because we always get whacked out
inflation is through the roof gas prices
are high restaurants are expensive
wouldn't it be nice to have an app where
you got a little cash back you get to
wet your beak a little bit and i know
what you're thinking it's too good to be
true it's not i'm telling you you gotta
try get upside we got it
saving a little money yeah make some
money on a back end
multiple streams of income my girlfriend
asked why i ordered three appetizers i'm
making money we'll get upside down
losing money if i didn't eat all this
stuff of course uh to get started
download a free get upside app in apps
in the app store or google play use our
promo code garbage and give you five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more look at
that they're whacking you out right away
hey you're right when you walk through a
girl like like a good tit bam hit him
keep him coming drop ten bucks easy next
claim an offer for whatever you're
buying on get upside check in at the
business pay as usual with a credit or
debit card and get paid in comparison to
credit card rewards or loyalty programs
you can earn three times more cash back
with get upside you can cash out at any
time to your bank paypal or an e-gift
card amazon or other brands there you go
get upside users earning more than a
million dollars every week holy cannoli
that's a lot of screech where i come
from it's tax time i could use the
couple of bucks
uh that's probably why they have a 4.8
star rating on the app store not bad
that's better than my uber rating which
is a 2-2
uh download my credit score download the
free get upside app and use promo code
garbage to get five dollars or more cash
back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more that's five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars or more using promo code
garbage now back to that show back to
the show
who's at fault or who should apologize
if you go to a bathroom
and
you open the door and someone's in there
peeing they didn't lock it
because i had a guy that's a guy who
does that that's on me if you don't lock
or close the door forget to lock it a
lot i do i pissed with the door what i
don't know i'm talking about a single
like a single bathroom oh that's him
that's always him yeah yeah cause i had
a guy give me she's there you don't
[ __ ] knock i'm like what to put the
[ __ ] door [ __ ] it wasn't an
apartment
nice piece by the way oh you saw cause
typically your backs to the door i
caught a peek
leaning in hey buddy star is anybody in
here
holy cow
because you know the boss is around here
you italian
alien dudes always had heaters
not me
nope also under puberty at 24.
i got a little italian at me
not the bottom half um
all right let's see here like a meatball
though
a meatball guy
of course dude meatballs are all right
you meatball guy
i'm gonna have meatballs tomorrow for
easter wow the meatball sausage ham
they're the whole nine i didn't know
they had them at the last supper but all
right
really that's like the third time you
push the last supper bit off air
i'm sorry i was in a i was in a dream
world of of of a crock pot full of
steaming hot tiny little meatballs i'm
all about it man what we're doing get a
couple of fresh amoroso rolls pre-sliced
make a sandwich get yelled at cause
they're supposed to be for hors
d'oeuvres
[ __ ] to overs yeah
um i like it like a swedish meatball
this is from st louis show off this
guy's got two pretty good heaters and i
rarely do a back to back wow
very rarely
um
never have one red ten dollar homie
bringing the tour to st louis we're
working on it there you go um
we just gotta pick up some bulletproof
vest first
is it tough down there it ain't good
really we're waiting on our ghost guns
ghost guns
hey you don't read the paper
no spend a little less time on tick tock
and find out what's going on in the
world they got these ghost guns running
around okay they're like put together
they're untraceable um ah piqued their
interest huh not really i'm just trying
to move the show along
let's just start running guns what are
we doing here
a couple of [ __ ] midnight cowboys you
should start running
oh get me the guns
i just got a gun in front of you i'm
dragging you along
um all right uh
have you ever named a pet after
something supposedly fancy example a dog
named gucci
that's a tough luck when you name
something
fancy
ed hardy
come here ed hardy
um that's a tough look
that's like that's like the same thing
as naming a car to me what no that's
completely different
that's completely different there's
nothing wrong name in your car
your car is typically we've talked your
car is typically a piece of [ __ ] if
you're naming your car
okay
don't tell laddie that but okay what do
you mean the car that was just in the
shop last week because it didn't battery
by the way can i say shout out to
westbury no you can't
not unless they [ __ ] [ __ ] grease
the envelope the best customer service
i've ever had
t-bone bleep that no free promo
a good family-owned business
since 1983.
you turn around you got it on your back
the jeep pulls in
t-bone's doing graphic
the car the number comes across the
bottom behind it we cut the deal with
that yet and if you get dinner this
saturday savings will blow your mind
t-bone will be broadcasting live from
the parking lot
i used to love that [ __ ]
man that was like the state fair when
they would do that they were big those
local um
who who used to do it on the boulevard
in philly like matt black kia or
something we want to see in ikea it
definitely couldn't have been ikea
why because kia wasn't around back then
i don't know was it i don't know it was
real low rent if they were pushing that
in the late 90s okay was around in the
90s for sure my aunt had one she did
calm me broad
[Laughter]
i thought they were already
1944 they've been making these keys
how long has jeep been around oh
let's go
go to the matrices you're crazy
definitely older 1941.
yeah
the war they had them in a war that's
where they started jeeps in the war
storm the beaches and normans and now
they're made in mexico
i bet you there's
see how many kias versus jeeps are made
in the u.s
key is big here it's kia all the way
toyota
anyhoo i didn't see any kias in the
battle of the bulge though
so i see you battle the bulge every time
you get a jeep
nothing on it that's cute what kind of
what kind of kid what's your model uh
what do i got i got a forte oh hencho e
mexico
you don't cut this
i'm a patriot goddammit
i'm getting rid of this goddamn lease
can't be driving around in a bill forte
he got me in a korean car made in mexico
i'm all jammed up
i pay my goddamn taxes
this guy's on a list somewhere
jesus christ
i got a north korean forte
it's just me and dennis rodman cruising
around
dude once you get in you can't get out
there's no internet service in there
kevin got the kim jong-un
with the moon roof
very nice
kim jong moon
kim jong moon
no one sent this to north korea yeah
anyway that's west berry jeep
this saturday i could just imagine
t-bone setting up a folding table in the
parking lot and you yelling at
that's good
all right where where oh his other
question is did you have a good couch
growing up
no no we never never had anything good
growing up no that's not true when we
lived in wilkes-barre the second home
that i lived in in wilkes-barre that had
a that had a um
a front room i think we called it a
living room
now we called the living room the living
room that's the family room where i come
from yeah see that's that's
that's 90s rich kid [ __ ] there was no
family rooms then would you have living
room one in living room two that doesn't
make anything i think they called it the
parlor
that's tough couple you you doing a
couple of parlor tricks some hand stands
and i got your nose
oh i would kill it in there i was the
king of the parlor i'd open up for my
cousin she'd do michael jackson i'd do a
little crazy eddie maybe a robin leech
get the crowd juiced up little crowd
work
and that's after thanksgiving meal when
they're all tired saying a friday
anybody can do a friday saturday night
let's see on a late thursday all right
when the apple pie stinks
um yeah we were living room family room
that's rich dining room
that's rich kid [ __ ] maids quarters
[Laughter]
um
living room dining living rooms rich kid
[ __ ] family room is rich kid [ __ ] the
family room was nice
family room is where you had the
sectional
probably one of those black boxes all
that kind of family room was the knock
around room living room was one you
weren't allowed in
yeah we had that in my second house
there was a good couch in there but they
were old they weren't like antiques from
like my grandmother
that we would have broken anyway
yeah nothing ever good happened in that
room ah it sucked man there's no there's
no tv we had this [ __ ] we just redid
ours probably
maybe like eight years ago
but it was 30
you know what are we talking about where
we where the piano was yes yeah that's
nice that's a nice sitting room yeah a
sitting room bob yeah maybe a salon they
would call it well get their [ __ ]
hair done in a living room
that's a term a salon no it's parlor
yeah but that's not what you call a room
with a fake cat in it
oh yeah shout out to sprinkles and he's
really going for the juggler isn't he
you pronounce that word
um
you talking about donatella versace his
cat
[Laughter]
see what i did i looped it back around
it's a circle i didn't get it um the
nice pet names dummy oh
you know who donatello versace is you
know who donatello is michelangelo
raphael leonardo sure like pizza um
what was i saying
oh but that room
got with they when they bought the house
in like whatever 88 or whatever
good year it was like
it stayed that whole motif
until
2012 or something damn it was
it was like walking back in time
everything was pink and green and smoke
in there oh man we had this [ __ ]
chair i mean it was like nice at the
time i guess
but this thing was blown out the dogged
[ __ ] on it peed on it chewed the bot it
was tough i don't know if i've ever
asked you this
but you mean that's what i'm here for
you made me think of it the rooms that
didn't have tvs really sucked
for them as a kid why the [ __ ] was that
what i'm saying why would you ever go in
there did you go read did you ever have
any of your friends growing up
who did not have either cable
or a television
at all at all no you're all you're
that would be you know you're from the
mountains too so it's a little more you
know it's tough to run cable through a
[ __ ] had a couple of friends no tv
no tv
no i mean i got to think 90s cable was
like already [ __ ] booming at that
point
to not i mean certain
i was from the time of certain rooms
would it like only one room would have
cable in the house sure
nobody had cable in their bedroom no
what are you crazy yeah we still don't i
remember i remember i was like in high
school i'm like mom i'll [ __ ] pay for
it let me just get some [ __ ] skin
amex up here what are we doing
i'm like i'll pay to run the [ __ ]
cable me and my brother like how much
does that run the cat like when i'm
drilling i'm trying to get some on the
job experience also they told me
it was impossible and i remember being
like you can't tell me it's impossible
to get cable in a room this is crazy
i hate those lies my mom told me she had
a shot so she couldn't have another kid
because i wanted to have a baby brother
like i had a shot my aunt blew
i'd do a daily shot
but yeah i remember being at a kid's
house one time i'm staying for the
weekend i'd never been to his house who
goes away for a weekend to a kid's house
we were going somewhere on saturday with
his family also do you have gold and
silver on right now yeah that's right
okay
really living that haircut huh
i crumble i haven't been flashing
where's the rag top at i haven't been
flashing because i'm not sure if it's if
it's a woman's chain or not that's got
that's got ladies written oh that should
come with a pair of white gloves my aunt
gave it to me yeah
your aunt gave it to you yeah
i think my mom had gotten it for her
years ago and when she passed away she
she she bequeathed it to me way to make
it fun
[Laughter]
can you tell it's a ladies though it
doesn't look i'm okay with it it doesn't
look manly really
huh i'm not saying it looks bad
but that flat yeah 80s that's 80s broad
smoking bernies my mom used to rock oh
this thing has been to bingo a few times
i can tell you that looks like she
wanted a bingo
yo did your aunts speaking of like
old-timey furniture i just put me in my
aunt's house they would all get together
and they would play scrabble and it was
a war dude did your family ever get
together and play games like that
we did as my age group of the family
which is about
with
husbands wives and girlfriends
boyfriends is about 20 of us
strip poker
what a mind it uh every thanksgiving
spin the bottle you know what i mean
seven minutes in heaven
seven minutes it was seven seconds how
was it seven minutes knocking brought up
come out smoking a sick he'll put me in
there for seven minutes oh full i'm
coming out sleepy it's seven minutes
dude
is it those chicks just didn't want to
be anywhere yeah
got one whiff of your undies let's do
0.7 seconds in heaven wait what is it
really it's seven seconds seven minutes
seven minutes
seven minutes in heaven jesus christ
yeah seven closed in seven minutes you
shouldn't be on the sales team i'll tell
you that us was seven seconds in and out
what were you doing in seven seconds get
a little feel a little smooch all right
i've had enough just to taste that he's
like this guy's dumb enough i can tell
him seven seconds you just need a little
something for later because you know
you're a young man seven minutes
and deals i'd stand there quietly and
get prepared to lie
she was all over me
i was in there by myself
[Laughter]
got your fingernails painted
i'm making out with a coat
that hornet sip up in there really
really was into me
[Music]
[Laughter]
what was the other one deep six did you
guys do that where you would
you murder a guy
you guys you guys never played the first
48 huh
what are you talking about
deep six was a was a character on gi joe
uh no deep six was like you would like
in i never i'd never did it you would
that's that sounds like a lie no i swear
to god it's just scary going is it deep
enough
no dude
i'll tell you it's sick you're more like
a deep three and a half
deep four and a good day
a shallow four
um no it's where you t-bone you and your
[ __ ] dirtbag
friend this is how to come across your
your radar at some point
um was real like cky-ish you would like
inhale
a couple times and like do this oh
people would push on your chest you're
talking about making out and [ __ ] like
that i know but you're talking about
asphyxiation
same thing
that's what that's how i get off we did
that we did that in grade school what'd
you call it we ruined it um i think pass
out or something like that
a couple of eggheads over here the
marketing department was still getting
their feet under them
back in the 80s we called [ __ ] straight
uh i think we ruined that for you guys
want to do rejected in heaven or pass
out
what do you guys want to do here i think
we ruined that for your generation
because a lot of kids a couple of kids
went down had seizures and stuff like
that from doing that but it did feel
good for a second speaking i ever tell
you the story we were in health class
and we were out in one of those like
trailers because the school was like got
too big so hell trash like all the elect
that what a specials or electives or
whatever they were called of course yeah
music they were all like out in those
[ __ ] catching your high school those
double lines catching your high school
or school in a rebuilding year you
really get the shaft yeah i don't give a
[ __ ] they weren't just i mean they were
permanent for
10 20 years there's like rabbits out
there in the woods multiplying
jesus christ do some push-ups or
something are you so i don't know if i
ever told you that i don't you say
seizure just came across i only saw a
guy have a kid have a seizure once he
was bit of like a teacher's pet nerd
kind of kid and we were in health
classes so he had it coming
he deserved it
nobody help him
let him shake it out [ __ ] a piece of
[ __ ] no
no
he's swallowing his tongue good so we're
sitting there and the health class this
is like out of like [ __ ] you know a
bad sitcom
the lecture or whatever the the study
for that day whatever the curriculum
was about seizures and what to do if
someone's having a seizure and this kid
jeff
[ __ ] seized out what a kiss ass
mid-lecture so we're like oh this is a
setup
it was literally like these are the
seven things and then as he read number
seven jeff hits the [ __ ] deck i saw
this on the practical jokers last night
so [ __ ] i wear sal and the other
guys
i know you're back in the coat room
looking for him check him for an
earpiece real quick
pattin them down i've seen this before
um so we all thought it was like a thing
of like hey you hit the deck and i'll
show them how it's done
so nobody moved at all
and i start panicking that's like my bad
i have like insane fighter if i start
seeing like it's like real panicky real
calm cool collecting oh dude i've
i ran out and i'm like what should i do
right now to go get like a nurse or
something there's a teacher in there
isn't there yeah he's a gym teacher he
doesn't know what mr d'angelo or
something he's just he's hitting on the
cheerleaders he don't know what's going
on you run back in i need a hall pass
can you sign my slip
and i need the bathroom key real quick
so did he save the kid
uh it was one of those i don't i forget
i think he's no longer with us he threw
a kickball at him
dodge ball get up you nerd
um
but i remember running into like i'm
going to the gym because like kids were
in gym and i was like that's like the
easy way to cut through like the gym
door was right like a
side door to the gym was right by the
trailer otherwise i had to go like
around
two-thirds of the building if that makes
sense okay so i'm like
i'll cut him off you jumped into action
yeah what's everybody else doing i think
i was by the door and i think he said
someone go to go get the nurse or
something so [ __ ] kippy this guy
they're talking [ __ ] about how to save
somebody's life i gotta put my everybody
panicked
i gotta put my cape on jackie moon
somebody hit somebody
uh no he was like go and i think i was
right by the door so like i go i'll go
and i ran but then like i didn't ryan go
get me a cup of coffee
try to figure out what to do let me get
my head on straight here who's got a
light huh
have either of you administered or seen
someone give someone the heimlich
maneuver no that was a question i think
we have you ever i don't think we ever
got to it was a home run um that came in
not too long ago have you ever received
the heimlich
received it yeah now
i've had a couple i thought
i was eating real stringy bacon one time
from a bodega do you ever get like
they some of the new york city of
bodegas give you like the worst bacon in
the world it's oldish it's old it's not
even cooked i'm like this was never
straight at one point ever it's like wet
paper towels oh dude it's horrible what
kind of pig did you get
[Laughter]
part of it's cold you're like how is
this hot and cold at the same time dude
bodega meat sometimes i'm like this big
got a 900 on the s8 yeah yeah what did
this pig have
i don't even [ __ ] i don't even talk
with it anymore you can't go to a
regular wood they've all transitioned to
that too all the bodegas transitioned to
that just like lump of meat where they
like rip off two people hate that [ __ ]
you can't even chew it no it's either
too fatty or too hard ruin your bacon
egg and cheese yeah so i i stopped doing
that
is that what the teacher had you get
yeah no he said the high oh i got i had
one other piece of that bacon stuck like
half him that's a panic
and i was just doing this so it would
like dangle at the top of my mouth and i
could breathe and i was home alone
oh man talk about your life flashing
before your eyes for like three minutes
i was like
the dog's looking at you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
pull it out
i pulled it out finish the sandwich
sands bacon put the bacon back on it
now my i saw my aunt do that to uh my
cousin
we were we were at the hungry pilgrim
which was okay yeah i think it was the
capital grill
the hungry pilgrim it was a restaurant
that was in the mall at the plymouth
meeting mall their apple cobbler was
huge my brother my brother found a
staple in his one time jesus everybody
eat for free
side note we brought the staple with us
no my cup my cousin who was maybe like
two or three at the time started choking
and my aunt sprung into action grabbed
her held her over
pat it on the back coughed it up [ __ ]
saved her life yeah
it's all right yeah
i had a couple of heroin addicts not out
on me when i was uh doing heroin
bubble gummers couldn't handle their
[ __ ] [ __ ] weekend warriors
[Laughter]
now they were uh
we probably shouldn't have left them
into the restaurant it was at devon
seafood in rittenhouse square they
rolled in like 11 o'clock on a friday
night the woman was wearing a hospital
gown underneath uh her like shirt
and they both had hospital things they
sat down they each ordered like a four
pound lobster and god love them they ate
the whole thing they tipped well but
they were nodding out during the meal
they were there for a while you know
like i'd walk by and they'd just be
uh-huh you guys done with that
and then they would eat it
i didn't life save them or anything like
that yeah hit them with the narcan yeah
nothing like hey who's your plug
but i wouldn't
i would jump at that opportunity if
somebody was hurt and then you know i
would try to help
obviously
yeah it'd be like a real who put cookies
in his mouth vibe with you i'm sure
maybe uh-huh
i mean we're leaving a football game
down at the link i don't know if it was
like a temple football game or i forget
what it was
i forget and we were walking or it might
have been a baseball game and this guy
just [ __ ] fell out
and someone's like is he a diabetic and
then just started they had like one of
those big lollipops that they got from
like the comically big ones they were
like trying to put that in his mouth and
i was like this is good this is going
south i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
there's always that one guy at a scene
like that there's an accident everybody
gets out there's always one guy who
sucks who's not helping but he's like
armchair quarterbacking it he's like
don't do that you'll blow the gas tank
like shut the [ __ ] up dude what kind of
guy has a gas tank the car i was we were
talking about people oh
okay i have a gas tank building up right
now to be honest with you
that's pretty gross um
all right this one's from a sandwich 10
homie haven't had one read yet have you
ever used the force to open an automatic
door
i use the force
all the time and every once in a great
while i just check to see if i can do
if the webs will come out of my hands
okay
sometimes i try to do the force just
normal like just go like that and see if
i could do it anything ever work no
nothing
you keep trying though yeah i keep maybe
one day yeah it just clicks in oh i'm
just doing my laundry and sit there and
try to work on my spider spiderwebs
work on your webs i'll do your undies of
course you walk in you do that thing as
the doors open that's what he means
right i believe it's like the jedi force
yeah
yeah it's the best i do it every time
yeah
never crossed my mind today of course
because you're not fun and you don't
like science fiction yeah well i am you
buy shitty bacon apparently like you've
never been on the bad end of it you bald
knew what i was talking about you all
went on in detail about said bacon and
now i buy bad bacon you know what
unfortunately out of here you didn't get
that big on good bacon all right tubsy
[ __ ] judging my bacon get the [ __ ]
out of here we're a hatfield family
right down the line boar's head has that
tick cut stuff now intimidates me i go
when i buy bacon now i bought some the
other day i don't like the thick cut
it's like nine bucks by the way six
pound i think it's 11 at my place um
i go with the standard what is it like
oscar meyer the yellow pouch it's all
perfectly sealed it's great there's
nothing better than that
a fresh thing it's like a set of stairs
a fresh thing of that on a saturday
morning
maybe some some some some some flapjacks
being cooked up on the thing that you
take out and plug in yeah i mean i don't
know there's water coming out of your
lip and i don't know where if it's just
oozing from the sore or coming from it
was a bottle of water i was drinking
curse of the ooze over here
because the legend of the youtube
whatever you what was it
legend secret of the year
thank you nerd alert
hey can i use the force to get toby out
of here
yeah doing the force is awesome that um
i'll best job i ever had yeah
what's a real dirtbag move when it comes
to automatic doors is like opening the
exit one
you know you can just open up like if
you know how there's an entrance and an
exit like say there's two different
automatic doors where's an automatic
door
oh i'm sorry i was thinking on a car
i think like an emergency door like the
back of the bus how did we get the cars
i don't know man you are somewhere else
sometimes
i'm thinking about the force and my jedi
training um so yeah you know you walk
into what there's there's an entrance
and an accident they're both automatic
doors you know you can just open up the
exit
i thought you had to push the button up
in the thing yeah you just you just pull
it open oh and then my construction days
you feel real cool yeah but then they
yell at you at the grocery store when
you do that maybe this guy works here or
something what's going how does he know
about the secret door trick that's what
i think they're thinking take me to the
deli
slice thing here here to inspect the
roast beef all right we gotta wrap it up
we gotta get the hell out of here we do
gang we love you we love yous as you
know moon tower we're gonna be there
don't make us look like bozos if you're
in the tejas areas
get to see the actual ayg show it's
gonna be a good yeah we haven't done it
in austin yet so it'll be it'll be a
hoot we have not and for our our uh
compatriots out there in the windy but
also it's for t if you can buy tickets
if you don't have a badge of moon tower
but if you have a badge to moon tower
you can go as well
yes as i was saying for our compatriots
out in the windy city we added a show
in chicago
yes so late show grab some ticks let's
[ __ ] park
we have some
pittsburgh detroit buffalo we're coming
back baby we promise we're going to be
there in june right yes fantastic we
love you we'll see you next week
[Music]